i was pumping gas most definitely
printing t-shirts and selling ink pens
and you know i mean every any anything
and everything
there was a guy who i worked with many
years ago and we were talking about
success and money and all that stuff and
um he told me this one thing he said you
know money doesn't
change anybody
money reveals them
you know
same thing with success and uh i i i
believe that you know
wholeheartedly i'm still exactly the guy
that used to pump gas you know i'm still
the guy that was a mechanic for a minute
you know i'm still exactly i just happen
to have a weird weirder job at the
moment if we could celebrate
every breath
that we take because nothing's a
guarantee
if we could celebrate the breath
and the exhale which is
being alive
without
you know oh my car won't start there are
things that are very very important in
life that we
we just we don't think about you know
and one of the most worrisome things
that i went through for years is
you freaked out freaked out about your
past
you're worried you're scared to death of
the future but the now doesn't exist
and i think that's a grave mistake that
we make
by the time you were 15 that you were
already had lived in 20 different homes
is that true uh my mom liked to move a
lot
a lot a lot yeah one time we moved from
one house to the house next door so how
do you adjust how do you get to be you
know every if you're going in a
different school all the time it was
kind of normal for we didn't know
anything else you know so for us it was
kind of normal i moved to los angeles in
1983
and uh
wasn't basically an unemployed musician
and uh
a buddy of mine nicholas cage yeah i was
filling out job applications and uh nick
suggested that i meet his agent because
he felt i should be an actor why
i don't know don't know still don't know
okay but no so you never seriously
thought about it until nicolas cage
mentioned it yeah i mean for me it was
really just i just thought well you know
at this point i'll do anything i just
got to pay the rent you know i was on
the verge of being evicted so you
consider yourself lucky you're very
lucky yeah but you have to tell them to
meet the luck right somebody hands you
the ball
and you run
you know i mean and if you get hit you
get hit or
maybe you make it through
you never know but i mean i i just know
that somebody handed me the ball at a
certain point and i was hungry enough to
keep running um
and i'm still running i maintain a
hunger
but not an ambition you went
to play music when you quit school you
didn't go to become an actor i started
playing the guitar at the age of 12.
yeah it was the first real passion that
i had so i literally don't remember
going through
puberty
because i locked myself in a room at the
age of 12 12 13 and
i just
played the guitar learned things off
records and taught myself how to play
and it was my life
and it was the only solace
it was the only
sanctuary it was the only security it
was my first love you
have to realize that whatever your day
is whatever you're doing whatever your
job is whatever people think of you or
project you to be
none of it matters uh really until you
look around and see
people who
who are in need
and
i think the probably the best benefit of
my job is to help to make people smile
who otherwise uh wouldn't or couldn't
have a smile on their face so um
yeah that's my deal to go into a place
where you know i mean i spent time in
great ormond street where where it was i
was i was the parent
uh when my daughter was ill and it was
uh
i mean it was i've known darkness in my
life but that was the darkest period
ever you know
i'd always kind of done these visits but
after that the visits became more and
more important
because
the kids
bless them you know they're so strong
they're so courageous
but the
parents
are the ones who are
slowly dying
and to be able to bring a smile
or a giggle um to these people is uh it
means everything in the world to me do
you look back and say look i did what i
wanted to do it's defining of me there
were other things that i probably should
have done
not
from my perspective i mean from my point
of view i did the right things every
every film
that i've done i'm happy that i've made
that choice i don't have any regrets
whatsoever most people would say
that if you wanted to be a leading man
in a traditional way it was yours there
for the taking and you didn't want that
i think any actor given a certain amount
of
success or given a certain amount you
know
somebody hands you the ball you run with
it any actor could do that but i
it's not me it wasn't me i was on a
television series for three or four
years about four seasons and i was
without question
a product
not my own product that was somebody
else's product
and they shoved me down the throats of
america and it was a very uncomfortable
situation and i swore to myself that
when i got off that show i would do what
i wanted the way i wanted to do it and i
stick to that i mean i if i had to do
leading man things just to just to
continue to be an actor continue to work
nah i'd rather i'd rather go back to
pump and gas
what do you think when you look at those
pictures no really what do you think
well it was a strange time because i had
become this product and it made me very
uncomfortable yeah because i didn't i
mean being sort of labeled a heartthrob
well they just they just started to
build this image and it had nothing to
do with me and no one should accept
anything but the truth
to have to
suffer
the ignorance
of someone
lying to you for
some
type of gain
you've never seen any of your films ever
i tried to see one once
because the director asked me to i fell
asleep 35 times i feel the experience
i'm happy
with the process
is what i'm interested in the process of
creating
the process of
exploring the process of
breaking formula damaged characters are
more interesting because that's that's
what's great about about the work
everybody's damaged
everyone's damaged on some level and
i'm fascinated with human behavior i'm
i'm fascinated with
the flaws of the human being i mean i'm
just fascinated it's a strange thing
because the the greatest thing you can
do as an actor i think is to be
an observer and at a certain point
something bizarre happens
you're not
able to observe
in public anymore because
everyone is observing you so that's a
danger since may 27th when my daughter
was born
i have been floating
i
smile
constantly
which i never did before and you never
imagined you would have it this kind of
no you know you you can never everybody
tells you and you know you know what
they're experiencing you know it's going
to be something you know sublime but
you know you just don't you can't
imagine until it actually happens when
you when you see
this little angel
arrive
she's everything the baby is everything
it's so amazing my
little family it's just so it's
unbelievable it's uh
i don't know it's the only thing
that's ever happened really the only
thing
everything else is smoke what were you
worried when you turned 50 no you know
it it was like uh i mean it was just
wake up it's another day you know and
everybody makes a deal about you know
the idea oh 50 you know half a century
and stuff like that it felt like 40 to
me just felt like another decade really
you know i mean both grown-ups and kids
love him so much what is it about him
you think that makes
well for one i think he's a major talent
too he's awesomely good looking
three he's um
it's not like most people we know there
is something
offbeat about it that is
intriguing
and
ultimately attractive there's something
magical about
my kids call him uncle fun
you know
and uh he is
when you are with him
you are pretty certain that nobody else
is having as good a time as you are
i came here for
for you the people
who um
through whatever good times or bad
you know have stood by me trusted me
and you've um thank you
[Music]
you have no idea how much i appreciate
it
i love you